trailer Matt wall show the race Hustler
scraped the very bottom of the Barrel in
their desperate search for racism this
time they claimed that memes are digital
blackface quote unquote also AOC takes
to tick tock to valiantly defend
Tick-Tock from those who want to ban it
a Minnesota politician who pushes gender
transition drugs on children reveals
that he has no idea if the drugs are
safe or not and doesn't care Donald
Trump spends time during his rally
attacking DeSantis and in our daily
cancellation George Washington
University is dropping its Colonials
nickname because it brings to mind the
evil history of colonization but is the
history of colonization actually evil
well no not at all talk about all that
and more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
according to a recent poll almost
two-thirds of Americans do not have a
will you know death is not something
anyone likes to think about but it's
important to plan for the future and
ensure that your loved ones are taken
care of after you pass away whether
you're a first-time parent early in your
career or an empty nester it is never
too early or too late to write your will
and with epic will you can get it done
in as little as five minutes for just
119 if you ever considered who will take
care of your kids when you pass away how
about who will speak on your behalf when
you find yourself in a situation where
you're unable to make health-related
decisions for yourself who do you trust
to handle your financial obligations if
you can't do it these are some of the
hardest questions we face in life in
Epic Wheel is here to help you through
every step of the process epic world's
team of estate planning attorneys has
done all the legal leg work so that you
don't have to all you have to do is fill
out their step-by-step form and they'll
help you create your last will and
testament living will health care and a
financial power of attorney don't put it
off any longer two-thirds of Americans
do not have a will choose to be in the
smarter third of Americans who do go to
epicwill.com Walsh to save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package that's
epicwill.com slash epicwill.com Walsh
today
well CNN is a dying pathetic husk of a
fake news organization but at least it
still serves a purpose and that purpose
is making the rest of us feel smart by
comparison and a fulfilled that vocation
again this weekend with an op-ed on its
website from one of its senior writers
quote unquote named John Blake the
headline what is digital blackface and
why is it wrong when white people use it
yes digital blackface and no he's not
referencing uh Justin Trudeau's Twitter
account the digital blackface Scourge
according to Blake is much more
widespread that he explains quote maybe
you shared that viral video of Kimberly
Sweet Brown Wilkins telling a reporter
after narrowly escaping an apartment
fire ain't nobody got time for that
perhaps you posted a meme of supermodel
Tyra Banks exploding in anger on
America's Next Top Model I was rooting
for you we were all rooting for you is
what the name says or maybe you uh
you've simply posted popular gifts such
as and it is GIF a gif such as the one
of NBA great Michael Jordan crying or of
drag queen RuPaul declaring girl if
you're black and you've shared such
images online you get a pass but if
you're white you may have inadvertently
perpetuated one of the most Insidious
forms of contemporary racism you may be
wearing digital blackface
now before we go any further I want you
to think about what Blake has just
unwittingly conceded here he has
essentially admitted that anti-black
racism is a non-issue in modern America
he admitted all of that by by claiming
that white people posting Gifts of Tyra
Banks are engaging in one of the most
Insidious forms of contemporary racism
now whatever else we can say about these
gifts if they constitute one of the most
Insidious most Sinister most evil kinds
of anti-black racism in modern America
then that would mean that anti-black
racism is basically over
I mean certainly if we lived in a
culture where black people suffered
actual widespread systemic racism then
memes of Michael Jordan would not make
the top 10 list there were no gifts in
1850 during the slavery era but if there
were
nobody would have said that they
constitute one of the most Insidious
forms of racism at that time
if they do now then that should tell us
something
of course digital blackface is not a
thing and gifts are not racist but my
point is that we could actually concede
everything this ridiculous hack is
claiming we could Grant him the entire
premise
and it would only undermine his
underlying premise which is that
anti-black racism is a serious systemic
problem in modern America
in other words if he's wrong about this
subject he's full of crap but if he's
right about this subject he's still full
of crap either way this is one crap
filled man let's continue
digital blackface is a practice where
white people co-opt online expressions
of black imagery slang catchphrases or
culture to convey comic relief or
express emotions these Expressions what
one commentator calls racialized
reactions are Mainstays and Twitter
feeds Tick Tock videos and Instagram
reels and are among the most popular
internet memes digital blackface
involves white people play acting and
being black says Lauren Michelle Jackson
an author and cultural critic in an
essay for Teen Vogue Jackson says the
internet thrives on white people
laughing at exaggerated displays of
Blackness reflecting a tendency among
some to see black people as walking
hyperbole
another quick aside here we're all busy
people we have a lot going on well John
Blake doesn't he you know he has to he
has time to write a five thousand word
dissertation about memes that hurt his
feelings but some of us are busy which
means we look for shortcuts you know we
look for uh ways to assess and
understand things very quickly and
here's one if you're ever reading
anything
that mentions an essay in Teen Vogue and
it's not in the context of making fun of
the essay but rather it's citing the
essay as an intellectual and moral
Authority then you can immediately
disregard everything else the author has
to say on that subject or any other
subject
and if you are ever writing something
and you find yourself
favorably citing an essay in Teen Vogue
then you can know that you have at some
point in the past suffered some kind of
head trauma that maybe you don't
remember and you need to seek medical
attention right away
more from CNN's John Blake
quote if you're still not sure how to
define digital blackface Jackson offers
a guide she says it includes displays of
emotions stereotyped as excessive so
happy so sassy so ghetto so loud our
dial is on 10 all the time rarely are
black characters afforded subtle traits
or feelings many white people choose
images of black people when it comes to
expressing exaggerated emotion on social
media a burden that black people didn't
ask for she says we are your SAS your
nonchalance your Fury your Delight your
annoyance your happy dance your Diva
your shade your yes moments Jackson
writes the weight of reaction giving
period rests on our shoulders
well if you were hoping that there would
be some kind of um rock bottom to our
cultural descent into stupidity
now you know better because if there was
a rock bottom then the paragraph I just
read would have to be it a paragraph
which ends with the sentence the weight
of reaction giffing rests on our
shoulders
this woman is pretending to be somehow
emotionally burdened by Gifts of black
people according to her she walks around
every day carrying the cross of gifts
she is a Christ figure suffering and
sacrificing herself so that the rest of
us can have memes
this is how she presents herself and yet
this is not our intellectual Rock Bottom
we are still falling still plunging
eternally into the idiot Abyss
now you've probably heard enough of this
article uh you've heard enough after the
after the title really but here's a bit
more quote
some may say posting a video of Sweet
Brown saying oh Lord Jesus it's a fire
it's just for laughs why overthink it
why give people yet another excuse for
labeling white people races for the most
innocuous behaviors
but critics say that digital blackface
is wrong because it's a modern day
repackaging of minstrel shows a racist
form of entertainment popular in the
19th century that's when white actors
faces darkened with burnt cork
entertained audiences by playing Black
characters as bumbling happy-go-lucky
simple tense that practice continued to
the 20th century on hit radio shows such
as Amos and Andy put simply digital
blackface is 21st century Minstrel C
so without a hint of irony the article
repeatedly uses a RuPaul meme as an
example of this 21st century minstrelcy
but not because drag is the modern day
Minstrel show which of course it is okay
these are the menstrual performers of
modern America uh so we do have
menstrual performers in this country but
they're they're wearing Woman face
rather than black face
just as degrading just as dehumanizing
just as offensive just as insulting
that's not what the author means to him
RuPaul is an example of modern day
Minstrel
only when a white person on Twitter uses
his image as a reaction gif
One Last Time back to the article says
historical blackface has never truly
ended and Americans have yet to actively
confront their racist past to this day
Aaron Wong writes in an academic paper
on the topic in fact Minstrel blackface
has emerged into even more subtle forms
of racism that are now glorified all
over the Internet Wong says that digital
blackface is wrong because it culturally
appropriates the language and
expressions of black people for
entertainment while dismissing the
severity of everyday instances of racism
black people encounter such as police
brutality job discrimination and
educational inequity
an academic paper on the topic we're
told this is the kind of thing they
write academic papers about
the fact that academic papers are
covering the same subjects as essays and
Teen Vogue should tell you everything
you need to know about Academia
and of course they're all just following
tick tock's lead indeed Tick Tock has
been on the front lines fighting against
digital blackface for years now
um here's one example
hi Benji here and I'm going to explain
what digital blackface is digital
blackface is where non-black people use
images or emojis of black people to
express emotion online often extreme
ones like anger or disbelief sometimes
images are edited to indicate Blackness
for this purpose the intents may be
innocent but digital blackface like the
original use of blackface exploits
Blackness through media for
entertainment that over the use of these
images also reinforces negative
stereotypes that drive racial
discrimination we can use images of
people that are A different race it's
okay to enjoy popular culture we should
just be conscious of the impacts the
meter that we share online may have on
communities with less privilege for
example if you find you always use
images of black women to express SAS
consider the negative stereotypes you're
reinforcing and how the smart reflects
your own unconscious biases and try a
different image next time hope that
helps bye
you know I would really prefer if they
just yelled at us like they obviously
want to because this cheerful smiling
routine is is it's just intolerable
tolerable I mean there's something even
more repugnant about this kind of tone
hey guys hope you're having a great day
hey by the way you're racist if you do
this totally normal and innocuous thing
do as I say you white Devils okay bye
bigots love you
that's even worse and of course the
condescension is part and parcel here
patronizing smugly disdainful none of
that is incidental leftism is after all
an ideology of trifling tyrants
constantly looking for new ways to
manipulate us
the pettiness is the point
I mean these are people who invented the
word problematize which literally means
taking something that is not a problem
and turning it into a problem
they're trying to solve problems they're
trying to create them and they aren't
even hiding it they'll admit it
that's why this kind of garbage this
push to make every benign thing into a
racist assault on black Identity or into
some other form of bigotry even now
including memes may seem idiotic and
laughable and it is I mean it is idiotic
and we should laugh at it absolutely but
underneath the stupidity bubbling just
under the surface is the very real and
very Sinister agenda to control every
last aspect of our lives and of our
expression and of our words and uh our
thoughts
you know they they uh they don't want
you to do say or think anything without
referring to them first to see if it's
allowed that's why the the pettier the
better the more seemingly innocuous the
better because they want you to start
thinking that oh man like this this the
thing I thought didn't matter at all
it's like I can't even do this without
being a racist
that's the agenda
but whether we engage with this on the
surface level or we consider what lies
underneath it
our response should be the same
and the response again should be utter
contempt
stain
dismissiveness and mockery
that should be our response to them
that is by far and away
the only acceptable answer at this point
and a necessary answer
now let's get to our five headlines
Biden's plans to help struggling
businesses business owners in the wake
of covet lockdowns were to prioritize
black latino Native American and
women-owned businesses it goes without
saying that if the roles were reversed
if Biden had said his plans were to
prioritize white male owned businesses
uh which is Unthinkable there would be
outrage obviously if you own a business
you can't rely on the government to bail
you out you need to take matters into
your own hands and Innovation refunds
can help you do just that if your
business has five or more employees and
manage to survive covet you could be
eligible to receive a payroll tax rebate
of up to 26 000 per employee through the
ERC many businesses believe that they
won't qualify based on incomplete or
outdated information so don't let this
opportunity pass you by because this
payroll tax refund is only available for
a limited time go to getrefunds.com
Innovation refunds has already helped
clients claim over three billion dollars
in payroll tax refunds through the ERC
and they may be able to help your
business too this is not a loan
there's no payback it's a refund of your
taxes there's no upfront charge either
they don't get paid until your business
gets its refund so don't let this
opportunity pass you by there's no
excuse see if your business qualifies
for ERC assistance in just eight minutes
by going to getrefunds.com click on the
qualify me and answer a few questions
don't miss out go to getrefunds.com
getrefunds.com
all right so I think we're going to
begin with this late last week Minnesota
finally passed a bill that makes
Minnesota into a refuge state for child
castration and mutilation we've been
following the progress of this bill and
as expected it passed so parents can now
take their children across state lines
to Minnesota to have them abused and
butchered in the name of uh of uh
quote-unquote gender transition
if you want to know why this bill is
insane
um then well you only need to have a
conscience and a brain to figure that
out but also this clip will help here's
a representative Finke who is a male who
identifies as a woman
being questioned about the side effects
that's one of the main proponents of
this bill of this move to
um to make Minnesota into a quote
unquote trans Refuge state
well
his question about these these drugs and
about the side effects because this is
like one of the main arguments that
people who are Against Child transition
will make is that these drugs are
harmful and that they do a lot of harm
to kids
and so here he has been questioned about
that like what do you have to say about
about that
um and listen to his answers or his
non-answers rather
representative Finke do GnRH hormones
cause bone loss
representative Finke
thank you madam speaker
um that is not a yes or no question
um you'll have to talk to a doctor about
a specific treatment plan to have an
answer to that question according to the
nih.gov human clinical trials revealed
significant bone loss at the spine hip
and femur in patients treated with the
GnRH antagonist thus osteoporosis and
the resilient fragility fractures pose a
significant impact on health and quality
of life of the GnRH antagonist users
representative Finke are any of the
drugs that are prescribed to Children
also given and by drugs that mean
hormone therapies or quote unquote
puberty blockers
are any of them
prescribed to children
are they also given to violent sex
offenders with the purpose of chemically
castrating the violent sex offender
representative Finke
um Madam speaker I have no idea
representative Franson
thank you madam speaker
the answer is
labrin cause sterility in men
thank you madam speaker I don't know
representative friends
Madam speaker thank you the answer
members is yes
all right
to think that there are people who could
watch that video and then come away with
the conclusion that the dude with the
purple hair is in the right on this one
like I'm gonna be on his side
okay he's promoting and pushing these
drugs on children and then he's asked
well did does it have horrific long-term
side effects but I don't know who knows
who knows
um now now uh we will say that if this
exact conversation was happening say two
years ago
um
then he would have that he would have
answered he would have answered all
those questions and he would have said
no does it cause this as a cause that he
would have said no no it's 100 safe
and there's still plenty of trans
activists who will claim that but the
reason he doesn't say that is because he
is aware that uh that more and more
people are are aware of this issue now
and uh if he just straight up lies
people will know that he's lying
so you know so instead of just outright
lying
and and telling lies everyone will know
our lives is that as well I don't know
who knows not yet it's not a yes or no
answer by the way if you ever are at the
doctor and uh and you're you know asking
about uh they're trying to get you to
take some kind of drug and you say oh
well uh does it have this terrible
long-term side effect like bone loss
okay which is a debilitated debilitate
against severe I shouldn't have to tell
anyone that debilitating and severe
long-term side effect is bone loss
um
if you ask your doctor that does it
cause this well not a yes or no answer
now it kind of is like can it cause that
or not it either can or can't
um so a not a yes or no answer in this
context is a yes answer
no it obviously he's lying now he knows
he's saying we don't know the answer to
the question we know the answers to
those questions are all yes causes bone
loss uh this is a these luprons drug
drug use to chemically castrate sex
offenders that is a fact there's an
absolute fact uh causes sterility yes
another fact okay it's part of the point
of the way these drugs are used
um
and so that's all facts so he's lying
about that
but in this case the way he's presenting
it is
uh not only I don't know but I don't
care
just total dismissiveness
so we went from on the on the trans
activist side we went from oh all these
claims you're making about the drugs are
false and wrong and untrue
and now it's and now and now we have
entered the phase of well no one can
know for sure but who could really know
there's no way to know and then pretty
soon we're going to get to the part
where they start saying well yeah it
does cause that and it's good
we're gonna get there next
we are very soon going to get to the
point where they will answer and say
well yeah we're sterilizing kids good
it's a good thing we are
of course that's already what they think
okay it's already what they think it's
to them it is a good thing they are well
aware that they are sterilizing children
with these drugs
they're chemical castrating children and
they but they it that's not a that's not
a bug it's a feature for them
we are rapidly getting to the point
where they will admit that out loud
because this is always the way that
things progress first it's the denial
not happening then it's that well no one
can know we have to really and then soon
it's going to be hell yeah we're gonna
sterilize kids
and it's good thing we are
it always it's it's not happening uh
okay it is happening but it's good it
all with everything on the left it
always works that way it's not happening
okay fine it is happening and it's good
um
now let's stay on this topic for a
moment Grinnell College put out a poll
result showing that a majority of
Americans are not in favor of bills
Banning gender transitions for minors
okay so according to this poll
a majority of Americans will be on the
purple-haired dude's side okay
not in favor allegedly of the bills that
banned the stuff so a majority think
that it's okay to medically transition a
child according to this and trans
activists have of course swarmed on this
poll attached themselves to it like like
flies on feces uh here's just one
example Arie Drennen of Media Matters
new polls shows that the majority of U.S
adults oppose legislative bans on gender
affirming care for Trans Youth and you
can see the numbers there
supposedly
um proposed ban on children receiving
gender affirming Medical Care with
parental consent and what we're told is
that 53 overall oppose the ban
um
obviously among Democrats it's more 78
but still you got almost 30 percent of
Republicans
who oppose the ban and uh over 50 of
Independence who oppose it
what is this pull proof the poll proves
that language is very important
so you look at the wording gender
affirming care this is what people were
asked whether they support gender
affirming care
and the way they're asked the question
begs the question because the whole
point of the people who object to this
stuff is that it is not quote-unquote
gender affirming care but rather
Butchery it is the rejection of the self
of of the true self of a person's uh
true sex
okay so you're not affirming anything
not affirming any reality in a way
you're affirming confusion
they have taken aside just in the way
that they word the question and they get
a different answer because most people
don't know what these terms really mean
even now I think more people understand
now than did two or three years ago but
even now most people don't know what
these terms mean they don't know what
it's referring to
they just hear affirming and they think
oh well it must be good
most people don't even know that gender
affirming care is the new term for you
know that where where they used to use
the term sex change
or gender transition
which is why when you ask people if they
support sex changes for minors as
Rasmussen did a month ago the numbers
flip
in that poll when Americans were asked
if they support legislation making it
illegal to perform sex change surgery on
minors 58 said that they did support the
ban
so you've got the numbers almost exactly
flipping
depending on how you word it
but even sex change is euphemistic I
mean it even the term sex change
because it used to be they said sex
change and then they changed it to
gender transition then they change it to
gender affirmation
but it was always the pro-trans side
that was coming up with all these terms
and then coming up with new terms
because they decided you know this is
this is another thing that always
happens on the left they use a term to
like as a euphemism to denote a certain
thing and then and then people start to
realize what the term actually means and
what it really stands for and then they
have to change the term again so they
have to stay they have to stay sort of
one step ahead of the public
consciousness of on these issues
um so even sex change is euphemistic
it's euphemistic in in favor of the
trans side
because you can't really change your sex
it's not possible to do
the really revealing poll and I don't
know if anyone's done this
would be one that drops all euphemisms
and just ask people directly like
explain what the thing is don't use any
label or term for it just explain what
it is and say do you support that
do you think it's okay do you support
um the the chemical castration and
sterilization of children do you think
children should be given drugs that
chemically castrated sterilize them
period do you think that children should
be given those drugs
because that's what these drugs do
that's what it is plain and simple
there's no editorializing there it's
just what it is
or you could as I said you know you
could go a longer explanation you know
you use more than one sentence
say here's Lupron here's what it does do
you think kids should be given this
you ask that question and uh yet again
those numbers are going to you know
rather than 58 uh being in support of
bands it's going to be you know 75 or
more
foreign
and do you know why it would be 75 or
more because because also many of the
people
you know even even people who would say
oh I support gender transitions drop the
affirmation part of it that euphemism
even many of the people would say I
support gender transitions for minors
yes I support that
many of them also don't know what that
entails
they don't really know what that means
what it involves what these drugs do
they don't know that
if you tell them you're going to get a
different answer
all right Trump uh held a rally in Waco
on Saturday of course he uh spent a
while during the rally attacking
DeSantis
um he attacks DeSantis far more than he
attacks Democrats these days
but I'm not sure that the attacks
play well and I thought this was a
revealing part of the rally check this
out
long before this guy became Governor
Florida was tremendously successful
under Rick Scott
he was look whether you like him or not
Charlie Christ it was very successful he
was a republican at the time
but Florida's been successful for
decades in fact probably as or more
successful than it is now
but when a man you know you get them
elected and there's no quid pro quo get
rid of that word remember those words
quid pro quo with the perfect call I
made with the Ukrainian president
but when you're getting a guy so he gets
the nomination because of you he wins
the election because of you two years
later the fake news is up there saying
will you run against the president will
you run
and he says I have no comment I say
that's not supposed to happen
um okay
so a few things
uh Trump's entire argument against
DeSantis really is that is that it hurts
his feelings that the Senate that he
endorsed DeSantis not DeSantis has the
gall to possibly run against him I think
it's clear that the sentence is going to
run plus you have to do that Pierce
Morgan interview so
um
it hurts his feelings and it's offensive
to him that that just you know his
argument is that the sandus owes him
loyalty that's his whole argument that's
his argument against but uh you know
that might be how he feels about it
but in terms of the American people does
that does that mean that we should see
DeSantis is it like he wouldn't make a
good president because of that because
he because he had insufficient loyalty
to Donald Trump
I mean should the American people give a
damn
about that and this is this is and again
I know your Trump supporter Trump fan
you don't like this part of it but
Trump Rose to prominence 2015 2016
talking about issues that matter to
Americans
illegal illegal immigration was
obviously the big one
not the only one but that's what he was
talking about
these days he spends most of his time
talking about things that matter to him
it's like complaints that he has
personally and trying to make some sort
of connection as to why this should
matter everyone else he doesn't even
really explain that
because he can't you know
when it comes to the sentence he really
has no choice the Sanders has been a
good Governor he's been he just has been
I'm sorry he has been good
and uh and he has also enacted
conservative policies in a meaningful
way and in in a way that no other
Republican in elected office has in
years
that's just a fact
and to most Americans that's what
matters especially Republican primary
voters that's what we care about
can you can you get the policies can you
put them in place can we can we trust
you to govern according to the
principles that you pretend to to uh or
you know that you the principles that
you claim to hold can we trust you to
govern according to them that's the
question we have for any presidential
candidate right
um
the fact that some other politician is
offended because you know he feels like
you owe them loyalty he did that who
cares I don't care about that no no real
American voter cares about that
but this is what he spends his time on I
think it's I think it's a I think it's a
huge mistake
and if he wins the primary Trump and he
goes to the general it's especially
going to be a mistake there
maybe you get away with this in the
primary I don't know like maybe you get
away with a campaign that's like 90
focused on your own uh complaints about
things that are happening to you
in a general election no way that's not
going to fly
just won't
and when it comes to DeSantis uh
the attacks on DeSantis they play well
on Twitter okay they play there's a
there's a group of people on Twitter who
go for this stuff
he's not even getting cheers at a rally
at a trump rally you you rarely hear a
trump rally is quiet and awkward as that
nor should you it's a rally for you know
your rally these are your people it's
supposed to be raucous and unless it's a
you know unless it's a Biden rally that
sounded like a Biden rally
which is not good
um
but there there is a I think this is
just a catastrophic strategy in general
spent so much time going after the most
popular Republic elected Republican in
the country and a guy who's popular into
Santos not just because of stuff he's
saying but because of the stuff he did
we're not idiots okay the the
Republicans who support DeSantis
even if you like Trump more if you still
support desantas
um
we're not morons we like him because we
see what he's done and we we appreciate
that this is what we want
uh
so I I think this it's just it's I don't
think it's playing I don't think it's
playing outside of Twitter I don't think
it plays anywhere else and I think it's
a mistake
um
not unsalvageable people have short
memories especially in a political
campaign
Trump could pivot from this and just say
all right you know let's talk about
things Americans actually care about and
not complain about the scientists the
whole time
um let's even acknowledge that the
scientist is doing you know doing a
really good job
rather than rather than praising Charlie
Chris this is not the first time either
that he's praised Charlie Crist by the
way
Charlie Chris was better than DeSantis
that is not even Trump can't get away
with a line like that no Republican
Primary people are not going to go for
that
it's possible to Pivot to get away from
this to start focusing on issues people
actually care about
um possible
certainly possible
you know if he were to Pivot now
by the time the primaries really
starting Earnest and by the time the the
voting actually starts you know right
now is ancient history nobody even
remembers it
but uh I I don't have a lot of
confidence that that pivot will happen
all right
this is from business inside
representative Alexandria caser Cortez
said Tick Tock should not be banned in
her first video on the app on Saturday
the New York Democrats started her video
by saying this is not uh not only my
first Tick Tock but it's a tick tock
about Tick Tock do I believe Tick Tock
should be banned no
so she started a tick tock in order to
go on Tick Tock and defend Tick Tock
from all the people who want to ban it
in both parties
by the way uh let's watch a little bit
of that video so why would we be
proposing a ban regarding such a
significant issue without being clued in
on this at all it just doesn't feel
right to me and additionally this case
needs to be made to the public we are a
government by the people and for the
people and if we want to make a decision
as significant as Banning Tick Tock and
we believe or someone believes that
there's really important information
that the public deserves to know about
why such a decision would be justified
that information should be shared with
the public as well
great argument there it doesn't it just
doesn't feel right that's right that
really is her hug you can watch the
whole video it's that's essentially her
whole argument doesn't feel right
doesn't feel right to me
um
you know that's that at least that's the
argument that she'll present to the
public
doesn't feel right
well she also says that it's significant
this is such a It'll be such a
significant move to ban tick dog and I
agree it would be significant in that it
would be
you know it would be uh it would be a
significantly could be significant in a
good way
but it's also not
it's not significant in the way that she
she frames it
like it'd be this huge deal this huge
power grab to ban Tick Tock
um
it's actually not
it's it's really a pretty simple
equation here
all you have to do is is balance so it's
a balancing act and on one hand you have
the harm
that Tick Tock does
to the American people especially to
kids
and then you also have to you have the
harm that it that it does to children
who are obsessed with this app and spend
like all day just scrolling you know
when you've got when you've got millions
of kids who are spending hours a day
staring at their phone and just
scrolling through like zombies okay not
even not not not to even mention the the
content that they themselves are putting
on this app that will live in cyberspace
and infamy forever
um
so you have that harm then you also have
the National Security concerns and uh
and all the rest of it so that in one
hand
and then you have to balance that
against the harm done by Banning the app
and by saying okay there are a million
apps you can use but there's one that
you can't this one's banned
well what is the harm exactly so we know
what the harm is here and it's quite
significant what is the harm in this
hand that we're worried about
what's the uh like dystopian scenario
what's the worst case scenario from
Banning Tick Tock in what way does that
hurt us as a country
I know how it hurts us to have it how
does it hurt us to get rid of it
even she can't explain that
the people defending Tick Tock can't
explain it
none of them have laid out okay if we do
this here are the ways boom boom boom
I'll I'll lay it out for you bullet
point here are the ways that it harms uh
this country it harms the American
people to get rid of it
so does a lot of harm by having it
doesn't really no harm by getting rid of
it
it's owned by a Chinese company to begin
with so what's the problem here
there really isn't one let's get to the
comment sections
of the day
[Music]
Todd says internet accessible cameras
and microphones should be in every
classroom if people have to have body
cameras then or if police have to have
body cameras and there's no reason why
schools shouldn't have this available to
every parent yeah we talked about this
uh a while ago and I completely agree
with you you know there are it's it's
not a it's by no means a perfect
solution and there are
other concerns that you could have by
having cameras in the classroom internet
access to the cameras you worry about
the privacy and security of the kids but
it's not instead not a perfect solution
but then you have to you have to think
about what what's the consequence of not
having this kind of uh monitoring
ability of the teachers well we see the
consequences of that and so we're stuck
with imperfect Solutions and there are
ways around it I mean you could do this
and you could for example I mean
obviously if you were to have cameras in
the classroom with the and they're
accessible by the parents and yeah the
parents should be able to if my kid was
in a public school classroom which there
never will be but if they were I should
be able to go somewhere online and
whatever they are I should be able to
you know pull it up and see what's
happening see you know see what they're
being taught what's what's happening in
class I should be able to see that at
any time
um and there are ways to mitigate the
privacy and security concerns for the uh
kids now there's no privacy concern for
the teacher okay because when you're in
the the context of being a teacher when
you're when you're in that role of of a
teacher in a public school setting
government employee there's no privacy
there when you're actively teaching
okay now if you're in the faculty lounge
or you're going to the bathroom or
something then obviously that's
different but when you're in the
classroom and you are actively teaching
there shouldn't be any privacy there
shouldn't be a moment when you're
actually teaching when you would say no
I don't want anyone on the outside
seeing this
because if you're thinking that to
yourself then whatever you're doing or
saying you should be doing or saying
pretty simple
ways around it like uh well obviously
you you know you wouldn't just put the
internet feed on YouTube or something
it'd be on-school website you could only
be accessed through a password that the
parents have uh so that gives you
certain measure of security uh the
cameras would you know be focused on the
front of the classroom when the teacher
is standing it wouldn't be like well
over the entire class uh and that sort
of thing so there are ways to mitigate
security concerns but I think
you know we have the capability of doing
that these days we've long had the
capability and it is uh long past time
Jackie says my husband and I were
watching the show 1883 recently and
there was a scene where a pickpocket was
beaten and hung in the street when
caught I told my husband if we had
something like that in place there would
be little to no crime
um
yeah well certainly certainly a better
system than what we do which is just uh
you know we say to criminals okay well
be better next time
and then they do it again next time and
say well this this is the last chance
I'm warning you and then they do it
again oh yeah on and on and on
I don't I watched 1883 I don't remember
I guess that I I'm assuming a scene like
that
must have been I barely remember it but
it must have been at the close to the
beginning of the show right because uh
and if you're just starting the show I
hate to warn you this I know this wasn't
really your point but I have to warn you
that uh there's there's going to be uh
you know there's it's a it's a good show
for about two maybe three episodes
and then it hits some kind of threshold
where it becomes a woke
teenage soap opera okay where the these
teenagers having love affairs with like
Comanche Warriors who come and they're
all very kind and nice and
and then the main you know Sam Elliott
is like constantly crying all the time
and it's just it's terrible so if you've
watched three episodes I would just stop
there that's the end of the show as far
as you should be concerned
David says nip isn't really a slur it's
just short for nepon or nippines which
is how the Japanese refer to themselves
it's no more slower than slur than
or for that matter Jerry for the Germans
or Yvonne for the Russians or Tommy's
for the British all of which were used
during World War II in equivalent
context
yeah but the the main point there is
used during World War II
which is why
I I have been told since we talked about
this on Friday some people have told me
that oh yeah I'm really familiar with
that term people use it all the time
maybe there were some places where that
term was used for Japanese people uh
where you maybe grew up and you were
familiar with it I never heard it in my
entire life
not one time
uh I never encountered it on the
internet nowhere
so I think it's it's
that probably fair to say many more
people in modern America had never heard
the term as it applies to Japanese
people then had heard it
which makes the plausible deniability of
that uh you know sports radio host all
the more plausible
it doesn't matter anyway because he
didn't defend himself
so I can't defend him
honey says I firmly believe in
disassociative identity disorder but is
extremely rare and only comes about
through repeated trauma before a child's
default personality is solidified so to
speak typically before the age of six
the brain fractures in order to protect
itself there are markers for this
diagnosis that are not able to be faked
successfully but that's why people
online
um people pop online and hit record
instead of seeking professional help
most who have did had no clue due to the
Amnesia that comes with it it's a
horrible diagnosis and not something
anyone should wish to have
yeah I I still don't buy it I mean I
don't buy the disorder at all it was so
so we would agree that most of what you
see on Tick Tock the people probably all
of it the what you see on Tick Tock of
people claiming to have this disorder is
made up and we already know that it's
made up because even on the the terms of
this of this supposed illness is that
you know you have these other
personalities but you don't know that
they're there because your brain is as
you say fracturing so if you're aware of
the other personalities and you can even
like introduce them and call upon them
to like come to the surface and
introduce themselves
um that's not how that works that's a
movie plot and that's all that you see
on tick tock so I guess you would agree
with me there
and what you're saying is over diagnosed
but it's real I don't think that it's
real at all I I just think it's I think
it's completely made up I have done some
reading into this and um
you know it's there's a debate about it
in the psychiatric Community but there
is definitely you know a preponderance
of people who would say
it's it it's not real it doesn't
actually exist at all which is why
almost all the famous cases that come to
mind and there have been famous cases of
it have all turned out to be frauds
I don't even I don't think it makes any
sense logically I just don't think that
the human consciousness even works like
that so what so what are we saying that
you're a person's mind contains multiple
conscience so it's like essentially
multiple actual distinct human
consciousness distinct people inside one
brain
I think that's the kind of thing that
only makes sense
it only seems to make sense to us
because we've seen it in movies
it's only because of the influence of
movies that that kind of thing that we
think oh yeah sure the brain splits into
different pieces and each piece contains
its own Consciousness uh but then when
you actually think about it you realize
that well that doesn't make any sense
all right
uh and let's see Leighton Pierce says
moral midgets LMAO and other Walsh quote
I'm adding to my Arsenal actually I
think I said mental midgets but moral
midgets uh is even better and I I think
I'll start using that and finally Daniel
says Matt I've started following your
content last year following your uh Dr
Phil episode and a few months after I
realized I'm in the dark on too much
inside jokes especially a particular one
so I decided to embark on a journey to
watch your content from the beginning
I've had the pleasure of watching your
car videos and learn of your beekeeping
Journey but this one is especially
important I've just watched the video
that brought the birth of the SPG
don't worry your secret is safe with me
I won't tell anybody about episode 737
PS fellow members of the SBG please help
make sure Matt reads this on Monday well
Daniel you um
watched all those episodes and did all
that research which is commendable and
you've done all of that only to now get
banned from the show because you are
banned
um we don't speak of the origins of the
SBG and if you've been watching all the
episodes you know that and you defied
that one rule
well it's not the one rule there are a
lot of rules but that's the you know the
first one
we don't speak of the origins we
especially don't speak of episode 737.
we don't speak of it episode 737 does
not exist
for the SPG episode 737 it's like the
13th floor of a hotel let's we just
skipped that doesn't exist it's not
there we go from episode 736 to 738
there's no 737
and so uh you sir are banned but thanks
for watching
I want to talk to you about something I
don't usually talk about which is hair
not mine my hair is handsome and
Brilliant because I use Jeremy's razors
shampoo and conditioner I'm talking
about yours uh if you're not also using
Jeremy's restorative restorative let's
call it tea tree and argan oil blend to
wash your man you're doing it wrong and
are asking to be canceled you're this
close to getting canceled Jeremy's
razors is more than a Razer company it's
a Men's Grooming brand that doesn't hate
men imagine that their shampoo and
conditioner along with their exfoliating
charcoal body wash are all made from
high quality natural ingredients right
here in the USA they're sulfate free
which is really important because you
don't want those sulfates whatever
sulfates are and even though I still
don't know what a paraben is they're
free of those two so that's really good
but most important of all Jeremy's
razors hair and body bundles are woke
free stop giving your money to woke
companies who hates you head over to
Jeremy's razors.com and check out their
shampoo conditioner and body wash
bundles today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
foreign
daily cancellation we moved from
problematic gifts to something a bit
more familiar which is a problematic
team mascots or in this case team
nicknames New York Times reports quote
George Washington University will soon
choose a new nickname for its athletic
team's drop dropping Colonials after a
year of pressure from students who said
the name was entangled with violence
toward Native Americans and other
colonized people the campus community
and the Heart of the nation's capital
has narrowed a list of 10 replacement
candidates to four finalists which are
ambassadors Blue Fog revolutionaries and
Sentinels
well uh just a side note here it's a
good thing that names like
revolutionaries and Sentinels don't have
anything to do with violence you know
that's really good personally um I think
Blue Fog is the best option it would be
quite appropriate to take away the name
Colonials which is something solid and
meaningful and replace it literally with
fog you know something hazy amorphous
undefined
it's the only way to avoid offending
people
if you choose anything distinct anything
that exists as a definable entity
somebody will find a reason to be upset
fog is your only choice but then again
even fog brings to mind a history of
racial trauma after all uh the media has
been reporting in recent years that fog
around the world is declining due to
climate change the website inside
climate news reported in 2021 quote with
a warming climate Coastal fog around the
world is declining but as we know
climate change somehow impacts racially
marginalized communities the most and uh
nobody knows how that's the case but
that's what they say and so this makes
any mention of fog potentially
triggering and problematic there's
really no way out of this bind in a
world where everything is racist the
only choice is to choose a team name
that doesn't mean anything at all
just mix up a bunch of like uh Scrabble
tiles and go with whatever gibberish it
spells out so you could be the George
Washington fifth internals or the George
Washington
ziglobots or whatever I think this is
the only way forward
more from the article quote the
university will hear feedback until
April 28th through what it is calling
moniker Madness and a new nickname will
be announced by the end of the semester
said Ellen Morin the University's vice
president for communications and
marketing the school's mascot will
remain George won George Washington's
head which uh which a uniform student
wears the change comes amid a reckoning
of the fraught history of team names
across the American Sports landscape it
comes after a push by students and a
victory for Native American activists
last year when the National Football
League team in Washington became the
commanders shedding a team name that was
a slur against indigenous people
notice how the the old name of the
Washington football team now can't even
be mentioned in news articles this is
the case with like any you know if you
want to read any article on ESPN that
mentions the you know something that
happened on that team years ago they
won't even say the name they won't they
won't print the name
but a couple of years ago they were
putting the name on merchandise and
selling hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of it every year
now you can't even say the name anymore
or at least I can they can't I mean I
will the team was called the Washington
Redskins for the record and still is
called the Washington Redskins as far as
you know I'm concerned
a little more from the times it says the
more we engage and the more we help the
community Envision what the new moniker
options might look like and give the
community a chance to try out what the
future might look like we're getting a
lot of positive engagement Miss Morin
said the colonial's name has been part
of the University's identity since 1926
we're replacing the hatchet Heights
Hatchet men axe men and crumen for Henry
crime football coach opposition to the
colonial's nickname erupted in 2019 when
the student body voted to remove it and
the anything but Colonials Coalition was
formed according to a report uh a
university moniker committee released in
the next year student organizations
delivered a petition to the university
president's office seeking a name change
quote Colonials were active purveyors of
colonialism and were complicit in
militarized and racialized violence
oppression and hierarchy the petition
said colonialism has been historically
and contemporary contemporaneously built
upon usurping land labor and autonomy
from racialized communities through
dehumanizing violence and suppression
well they're right about one thing
Colonials were indeed active purveyors
of colonialism the colonists did live in
colonies very important insight and
observation the rest of what they said
is nonsense
well that's not the the really
disturbing thing here the part that
disturbs me
disturbs me the most anyway
is when we hear from The Defenders of
the colonial moniker the people that
want to keep it this is what they say
quote
some alumni however remain attached to
the University's old name Miss Morin
said survey respondents with an affinity
for the Colonials associated with
revolutionary spirit and fighting
tyranny according to a report proponents
especially older alumni have argued that
it defines Americans during the British
Colonial area era said Denver bronzeman
an associate professor of history at the
University who's a member of a committee
that was formed to discuss the name
opponents view it as a synonymous with
violent colonizers said Dr brunsman a
George Washington scholar
now this is the kind of reasoning that
we hear a lot and not just in relation
to George Washington University's
nickname from people who are ostensibly
taking the rational and correct side of
the overall debate we'll often hear this
sort of thing they'll say well
you know when we celebrate and honor the
colonists we're not celebrating
colonization we're celebrating their
independent spirit and their toughness
that's all
both sides of the argument seem to have
conceded
that colonization was in itself a bad
thing
we cannot defend colonization in its own
right and so we must defend the people
of that era by pointing to the good
things they did
but here's the thing
colonization was a good thing they did
the conquest and colonization and
settling of this land was overall a good
and Noble and courageous thing
it is good that it happened and we
should be grateful for it
the people who came here and claimed
this land Were Heroes
it was heroic
and they were Heroes not because of the
other good stuff but because they came
and claimed it
for hundreds of years this would not
have been controversial to say it would
have been perhaps the least
controversial thing to say
and now you're not allowed to say it at
all but I will anyway
now not not all colonization is good no
there are evil forms of the practice for
example the cultural colonization that
the left engages in today when Western
governments fly the pride flag on their
embassies and try to export you know the
LGBT agenda and gender ideology into
Africa and other regions of the world
that don't want it
that is a form of ideological
colonization and it's evil
but the colonization that brought
Europeans to this part of the world
hundreds of years ago
um that was good
not everything that happened during
those many centuries was good obviously
history is not that simple people can
commit evil in the pursuit of a
worthwhile goal that happens all the
time but
uh and nobody would ever say that the
conquerors and colonizers of this land
were perfect angels
but we should celebrate them
and we should celebrate what they
achieved
this was all happening at a time when
much of the world was undiscovered
unsettled uncivilized
and it fell to Brave and determined men
most of them living of course long
before George Washington to get into
ships and sail into unknown sea to
discover unknown lands and then to those
after them men and women just as Brave
to settle that Wilderness and spread
civilization
they had every right to do it according
to the law of Conquest
which was the law that governed the
entire globe
and the law that every native tribe
lived and killed and died by
despite what you may be told a scattered
assortment of primitive tribes did not
own this entire hemisphere
these tribes which were about 3 000
years behind much of the rest of the
world if not four thousand years
um
did not have some kind of divine right
to keep this entire half of the globe to
themselves forever
they conquered whatever land they
occupied conquered it by brutality and
bloodshed every time and then uh and
then and then they claim thousands of
square miles of wilderness as their own
even though they weren't using almost
any of it and couldn't defend almost any
of it
and so a far more advanced civilization
came along and claimed it that's the way
of the world
and it's good that it happened
um what was the other option anyway
I mean let's imagine history the way
that these leftist idiots think that it
ought to have played out
the early explorers came to the Americas
they find primitive people living here
then they go home and say never mind
guys call off the whole age of Discovery
thing that entire part of the earth is
owned by people who haven't discovered
the wheel yet it's all theirs
the whole thing we can't go there
what happens next
the tide of civilization comes to a
crashing Halt and the Earth forever
remains divided by some kind of Time
Warp where one half of it lives three
thousand years in the past
forget about how absurdly impossible
such a scenario is would it even be
preferable if it could have happened
I mean it could not have happened it
could not have happened that way
it it just couldn't
but even if it could have would it have
been preferable would that have been a
better
um
thing obviously not
if this land had never been colonized
and conquered forget about the
technological advancements that never
would have been made
um certainly never would have happened
here and possibly never developed at all
forget about the absence of modern
medicine forget about the fact that
people would still be dying by diseases
that don't even put us out of work these
days
consider that instead that slavery would
still exist here
just as it always did among native
native tribes it still would
there would still be slavery across this
entire hemisphere
there would still be constant Warfare
where defeated combatants were tortured
and killed
women were captured as sex slaves
children were were either killed or
kidnapped
just as was routine among native tribes
there would certainly be no human rights
here
no democracy none of that
now I'm not saying that the early
settlers came here to spread democracy
obviously
I'm saying that
the people who Lament The settling of
this land
are lamenting the existence of
everything they pretend to cherish they
are pining for a version of this part of
the world where nothing that they value
or pretend to Value exists
and that is why they the
anti-colonialists are once again today
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to members block hope to
see you there you can become a member
and use coded wall should check out for
two months free on all annual plans uh
and if we don't see you there talk to
you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign